في مدينه حكت حولها الاف نظريات المؤامره
تبرز الان نظريه مؤامره غير مسبوقه تتهم
الولايات المتحده بافتعال الزلازل في
تركيا وسوريا والمسؤول برنامج هار الخفي
المتهم كونه السلاح السري الذي ستستخدمه
الولايات المتحده في اي حرب في المستقبل
اردنا معرفه ما حصل في تركيا وسوريا اثناء
الزلازل التي ضربت واختبار سبب الدمار
الواسع الذي لحق هذه المناطق علميا
فتوجهنا الى مختبر البروفيسور بيدروسيلفا
لمحاكاه الزلازل في جامعه جورج واشنطن في
العاصمه الامريكيه
الزلازل الطبيعيه جدا وسهله المناقشه واي
تفسير خارج ذلك هو تعقيد غير مبرر الزلازل
ليست السبب وراء العدد الكبير من الخسائر
التي شاهدناها في سوريا وتركيا بل ببساطه
المباني المشيده سيئه التصمي كانت السبب
وراء كل هذا الدمار ولا يمكن لاي زلزال
طبيعيا كان او مفتعلا ان يكون السبب
مشروع هارب الذي يشغل العالم حاليا هو
برنامج ابحاث الشفق القطبي النشط عالي
التردد التابع لسلاح الجو الامريكي تم
اغلاقه عام 2015 وتحويله الى جامعه الاسكا
يحتوي على 180 هوائيا موزعه على مساحه 14
هكتارا تنبعث منها موجات لاسلكيه عاليه
التردد تصل الى الغلاف الجوي للارض
وتحديدا طبقه العيون سبار التي تحتوي على
الغاز الايوني ولكن بنسبه قليله جدا ومهمه
هذا المشروع دراسه كيفيه زياده كثافه
الغاز المذكور وتاثيرها على الغلاف الجوي
وسحب البلازما متعدده الالوان المعروفه
باسم الشفق القطبي
البشر يستطيعون افتعال زلزال ولكن ذو قدره
بسيطه جدا ولا تتعدى قوته الدرجه الواحده
عبر طريقه واحده وهي ضخ نسبه معينه من
المياه في قشره رقيقه من الصخور
علماء من حول العالم اكد مرارا وتكرارا
انه لا يوجد دليل علمي واحد يربط بين
التلاعب بالتقس وطبقات الجو بحدوث الزلازل
على الارض حتى ان خبير الزلازل الهولنديه
الذي توقع حدوث الزلازل اي علاقه بين
التغييرات في الغلاف الجوي والمناطق التي
تقع فيها
الزلازلت سليمان العربيه واشنطن